what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be dealing
with the most recent events
in the boku no hero story and the fact
that some of our favorite characters
from class
1a are now in mortal danger we're
talking about momo
jiro kirishima mina kaminari our boy
mineta
and many more one or more of these
characters could be dead
in the next few chapters this is no joke
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content on this channel and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help
and if you happen to be new to anime pro
or you just haven't subscribed yet
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications a big thank you to all
of our anime outpour patrons who make
videos like this one possible
with the current state of youtube and
the world patron support
means more than ever so thank you so
much i'll talk more about patreon at the
end of this video but first
please be advised that this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
we are dealing with the very latest
events in the story so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
opens up with the students and heroes
who are near the villain mansion but not
on the front lines
realizing that gigantomachia has
awakened and that he is coming
their way jiro is the first to notice
thanks to her earphone jack which is
able to detect the fact that something
huge
is on the move the actual pro heroes who
are there on the scene decide to join
the other heroes on the front lines
but they tell the students to stay back
meanwhile
mount lady and the other heroes at the
mansion are still doing their very best
to hold gigantomachia back
but it's just too hard kiganto makia is
so big right now that he dwarfs in size
even mount lady and if that wasn't
enough he is also carrying a bunch of
villains
on his back it turns out that along with
dobby toga and mr compress
spinner and skeptic are also there on
top of
machia in fact gigantomachia was the one
who placed the villains on his back
before leaving the mansion
as per shigaraki's orders skeptic
actually wants to be put
down so he can stay and protect redestro
but
dabi explains that shigaraki must have
awakened ahead of schedule
and machia is only following his
master's orders
giganto machia is completely focused on
carrying out these orders
and he is determined to get to jakku no
matter how many heroes try to stand in
his way
now that i think about it machia is
actually a pretty big
simp for his master but that's neither
here nor there
the heroes at and around the mansion are
surprised to see that makia is awake
prior to the beginning of the raid they
were all assured that this
so-called walking disaster wouldn't
become an issue
and that's because he doesn't move
unless he receives direct orders from
all for one or shigaraki since all for
one isn't tartarus and shigaraki was
unconscious
when the raids began the heroes assumed
that makia would just remain
motionless however something clearly
went wrong in jakku
because makia just became the major
threat for all the heroes
at the mansion these heroes are now
doing their best to help mount lady
whose strength is giving out but
machia's skin
is too thick for any of their attacks to
pierce through
his back looks like a jagged cliff and
trying to take him down is like trying
to
take down a mountain but even though
gigantomachia is now the biggest threat
to the heroes
he is definitely not the only one ice
boy getting is still on the battlefield
and he is facing off against cementos
i always love seeing cementos when he
loses his cool
and in this particular moment samantos
is going all out and screaming at
getting
even the veins on his head are popping
out it's pretty crazy i'll say this much
about cementos
he definitely turned out to be a lot
more badass than we were led to believe
when the story first started at first i
saw him as just this
calm and harmless teacher but when he
gets excited
cementos is not someone you want to mess
with at the same time as samantos is
fighting getting
headshot is going head-to-head against
redestro
and it seems that redestro has been able
to get his legs back
although i'm not sure exactly how he did
it nevertheless
he is now able to use his super move
again the one that turns him into a
stressed out
dark hulk reed destro has also realized
that shigaraki must have awakened early
and he instructs all of the liberation
army soldiers to
follow behind gigantomachia redestro
proclaims that this
is the beginning of their revolution and
all the villains get pumped up by this
and they rush after makia meanwhile
kamui woods is carrying midnight on his
back and they are attempting to get
closer to makia's face
since physical attacks don't work
against machia because his body
is so impenetrable midnight wants to
neutralize him using her sleeping
gas quirk calmly at midnight arrive just
as machia
overpowers mount lady and takes off
running
kamui is of course concerned about mount
lady
but midnight tells him that they can't
lose focus
they have to get as close to makia's
face as possible and put
him to sleep if they can't stop makia
from getting to jakku
that entire city will be faced with a
disaster of
epic proportions at his current size
makia will level the whole city in a
matter of minutes
and he will surely annihilate everything
else that stands
in his path unfortunately for kamui at
midnight
as they get closer to makia's face they
finally realize that other villains
are riding on top of his back compress
uses his quirk to throw a bunch of
marbles at the heroes
which then turn into large boulders
while in mid-air
compress of course has the ability to
shrink large objects and even people
in these marbles and then release them
and turn them back to their normal
size whenever he wants as a result of
this attack
midnight is knocked down to the ground
and her attempt to put machia to sleep
flops and flops hard midnight
is disappointed in herself but she knows
that there is no time to waste and that
she has to come up with some other plan
she briefly thinks about which quirk
could be strong enough to stop machia
and in the end she decides to contact
momo and so
midnight tells momo that even though it
is against the law
momo must use her quirk creation to make
a powerful
sleeping agent i'm thinking that this is
going to be some sort of military grade
substance that will be strong enough to
put down
even the gigantic machia as the
liberation front members who are
following gigantomachia catch up to an
injured midnight
she puts her faith in momo she tells
momo to make the sleeping agent
give it to one of the pro heroes and
then take the other students and
evacuate
immediately and that is the last that we
hear of midnight
because the villains have arrived and
the connection between momo and midnight
is severed momo is now under a lot of
pressure as a result of this situation
she doesn't know what to do midnight
trusted her to use her own judgment
but she doesn't know if she should just
run away in order to keep all the other
students safe
or stand and fight even though that
would mean putting her life and the
lives of all of the other students
at risk ultimately momo decides that
they can't just run away with their
tails between their legs
and she tells jiro to use earphone jack
to determine how long they have
before machia arrives momo also tells
mudman
and the other students to get ready
because makia is about to arrive
and they need to work together in order
to find a way to stop him
jiro then warns everyone that
gigantomachia is approaching extremely
quickly
she doesn't even need to use her quirk
because she can see makia
and he will arrive in less than 10
seconds in this moment the situation
appears to be hopeless
10 seconds isn't nearly enough time for
the students to come up with a real
strategy
but then out of nowhere mount lady is
able to recover from her
earlier fall and with the help of
kamui's quirk she grabs hold of machia's
leg
this slows down makia but only slightly
he is still moving only now he is forced
to also drag
mount lady along with him as he moves as
all of this is happening momo is already
using creation to produce
canisters of that sleeping agent that
the students will try to use to stop
machia she hands the canisters out to
the other students
as they all vow to stand their ground
and defend their honor
as heroes they might still be students
but they are also on a hero mission
they are wearing their hero costumes and
they have to live up to their hero
values and principles even in the face
of
imminent danger and that is how this
chapter ends
with all the students preparing to face
off against one of the strongest
villains in the history of mha
and as strong as machia is he isn't even
the only threat
that is approaching riding on his back
are a bunch of other
overpowered villains including toga and
dobby and yet
more villains are following on foot so
if the students engage in a battle
against machia and it appears that they
will
they will also have to be battling all
the other villains
i have to say i am truly proud of momo
and the other students for how they
acted
in this insane and stressful moment and
i'm really rooting for all of them
but at the same time i'm extremely
worried for their safety
these are not just some minor characters
that we are talking about here
we have a bunch of class 1a students
here
characters that we have grown to love
since the very beginning
of the story including of course momo
but also
jiro kirishima mina kaminari ojiro sato
and the true protagonist of the entire
series mino rominita
not to mention the class 1b students who
are here as well including juzo and
tatsutetsu
the lives of every single one of these
students is now
in direct danger and it is possible that
some of them will die
within the next few chapters i think
that if they can come up with a good
team strategy these students will
definitely be a formidable force
but at the end of the day they are not
facing off against a few minor
or even mid-level villains they are
about to face off against
a walking mountain and some of the
strongest villains in the story
including dobby it's really hard for me
to believe that villains the likes of
makia and dabi
won't succeed in reaching jakku their
presence there is practically required
for a fully satisfying final showdown
with endeavour fighting shigaraki now
has to be the time that horikoshi
finally plans to have that fateful
encounter between
ng and dobby so while i look forward to
seeing what kind of strategy the
students will come up with and while i
wish them the best of luck
i don't think that they will succeed in
stopping the villains all together
although they might slow them down or
potentially stop some of them from
continuing the trip to jakku
i mean think about it if all of these
experienced pro heroes like
cementos headshot mount lady and fat gum
couldn't stop gigantomachia is it really
fair to expect the students to stop him
except for a few exceptions like
kaminari and tokoyami these students
were never even supposed to see
any direct action they were never
supposed to be on the front lines
and yet now they find themselves facing
off against some of the strongest
villains to ever appear
in the boku no hero world and not only
is gigantomachia strong
but he is also fanatically obsessed with
carrying out his master's orders
and he will do literally anything to get
where he needs to go
even if that means killing everyone in
his path
i really don't know how to feel about
this situation
on the one hand i love that the students
are stepping up in a time of crisis
like true heroes would but on the other
hand i am extremely worried that some of
my favorite characters could lose
their lives all of these students are an
important part of the whole
class 1a dynamic that we've come to love
and as such they play a major role
in the story as a whole let me know what
you guys think are the students actually
going to succeed in stopping machia
or are they just going to slow him down
temporarily are any of the other
villains like dobby toga spinner etc
going to be taken out by the students
and do you think that any of the
students could actually be seriously
injured or even killed
during this battle please let me know
what you think is going to happen next
down in the comments below this is
definitely
intense so far the much more intense
battle was obviously at jakku
but now the stakes are almost just as
high back at the villain mansion
some of our favorite characters could be
in serious trouble
and the next few chapters could change
everything
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content on the
channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime
pro or you just haven't subscribed
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications the way that youtube
works now you really have to go through
the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're gonna
miss a ton of our videos
even if you're subscribed i don't know
why that's how it is
but that's how it is you can also hit me
up on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar i want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
upper patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thanks to all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
alolan adam the world steelers acquired
respect
pate heffa jonathan king brandon aviles
papa smurf
the school bus king riser emperor otaku
ricardo martinez thomas jones kin mano
michael hyde and jaden the vector and i
can't forget all of our pro hero tier
patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson
kings eldress and anatoly kazatsuki on
hell cruise
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
octor jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie parks zodiac
12 rathune de ora kraken arles
and deadly saint if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you please consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you